[Applaudissements]
tout à côté il veut faire de plus en
plus de jeunes ce dernier ou pas il faut
absolument mettre des chemises enduit de
faire dieu sait qu'elle a 53 exact
d'accord et ben vous les faites pas du
tout je ne suis pas non mais vous êtes
très beau très bien conservés que jeune
d'esprit en tout cas c'est vrai qu'il
est jeune d'esprit à binche alesi dit
une phrase un peu de jeunes soir pour
voir si vous êtes jeunes à les y est un
gros vas-y on lance tout de suite le
hashtag grosse tristesse et dites nous
si vous aussi vous avez vécu des moments
de solitude comme ça des moments de deux
crises aux gamins la radio le soin et
tous nos gens se moquent du coup à faire
mais ça fait 1-0 fait une autre âge
lesquels j'ai quelques retours wave asie
écoute de roullours où tu vas voir c'est
de la balle à kout de julos et des
rouleaux commence à son différend qui
paraît un d'accord les ai dit moi par
angel the way hier soir je suis allée
une soirée c'était vraiment génial
on s'est vraiment beaucoup amusé why
hier soir une soirée de ouf
y'avait reçoit y avait des petits qu on
a tout explosé sa mère
[Rires]
jean luc qui lui parle bah je sais pas
mais en tout cas jean michel sage que
quoi qu'il arrive c'est 50 ans était
magnifique
[Rires]